wir senden meine damen und herren ist ja
hier schon ein bisschen grotesk die
veranstaltung sommerpause alle mdbs
zurückgeholt gefühlte 90 grad sind nur
sagen das wäre auch anders gegangen das
hätten wir anders lösen können aber sei
es drum
meine damen und herren die letzten
wochen die letzten wochen haben gezeigt
und annegret kramp karrenbauer wird die
cdu zu einem klub der unglaubwürdigkeit
sie frau kramp karrenbauer haben monate
monate für manfred weber als
kommissionspräsidenten geworben wir
kennen das ergebnis das ergebnis ist
ursula von der leyen
es ist aber so dass sie gar nicht zur
wahl gestanden hat ich glaube das ist
eine schwere verletzung der demokratie
was sollen die wählerinnen und wähler
von dieser unglaubwürdigkeit halten
dazu kommt dazu kommt wo von der leyen
ist mit den stimmen von den salvinis den
webers und auch den ordens gewählt
worden
immerhin immerhin den ordens gewählt
worden immerhin hat herr weber
der hat immerhin die stimmen von herrn
aber noch abgelehnt aber sei es drum
programm kam bei ihre glaubwürdigkeit
als verteidigungsministerin ist zum
start 0 ministerien das sehen wir werden
zu verschiebe bahnhöfen um die
personalprobleme der union zu regeln
das verteidigungsministerium soll zum
karrieresprungbrett der kanzlerschaft
werden
das heißt sie frau kramp karrenbauer
haben ein instrumentales verhältnis zum
verteidigungsministerium wollten sie
sich nicht voll der cdu widmen noch in
diesem monat und ich will sie zitieren
haben sie gesagt ich habe mich bewusst
entschieden auf ein aus einem staatsamt
in ein parteiamt zu wechseln ist das
glaubwürdig machen sie jetzt eigentlich
beides halbtags
kennen sie die vielen baustellen die die
hier heute alles schon genannt worden
sind im verteidigungsministerium von
beraterverträgen vom chaos in der
beschaffung und und und was sollen die
wählerinnen und wähler davon halten
glaubwürdig ist das nicht wenn sie
wirklich im übrigen wenn sie wirklich
das gewicht der cdu vorsitzenden in ein
zukunftsproblem stecken wollten dann
hätten sie doch umweltministerin werden
können das ist doch aktuell die
zukunftsfrage oder wenn das ein spd
ressort ist hätten sie doch vielleicht
das ressort wirtschaft und energie
energie als die zukunftsfrage nehme das
wäre noch halbwegs glaubwürdig gewesen
nachdem ihre einzige europapolitische
idee in einem flugzeugträger bestand
haben sie jetzt mit dem sogenannten zwei
prozent ziel heftig gerade am wochenende
nachgelegt will erstmal auch darauf
verweisen dass hat der kollege mütze
nicht getan das ist wieder den
koalitionsvertrag
und ich will vor allen dingen immer
deutlich festhalten das entscheidet
immer noch der bundestag keine regierung
und keine ministerin
wir haben eine parlamentsarmee und nur
hier wird entschieden und nirgendwo
anders
und diese zwei prozent das wären eine
beispiellose aufrüstung dies in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik so noch
nicht gegeben hat wir sind nach unserer
auffassung der linken jetzt schon auf
einem falschen fahre meine ich war ja
mal haushälter und als die 2014 aufhörte
da war das volumen 32 milliarden 2018/19
38,5 milliarden und in diesem jahr
werden es 43,2 milliarden aber mit ihrer
forderung ist das alles nichts
ihre forderung ist im kern ein kotau vor
trump und vor der rüstungsindustrie
meine damen und herren
offensichtlich offensichtlich soll die
nato in ein globales interventionspreis
verwandelt werden
willensstark sind sie insbesondere bei
der frage der aufrüstung
aber falls ihnen das noch niemand gesagt
hat nicht mehr die höchste zahl fordert
macht das beste für die bundeswehr schon
die 1,5 prozent sind ja im kern schon 60
milliarden ihre forderung ist nur
finanzierbar
entweder mit massiven kürzungen im
sozialbereich oder durch neuverschuldung
wo unsere kinder und enkelkinder für
diesen rüstungs waren zahlen müssen sie
sind unglaubwürdig weil sie gar nicht
zur finanzierung ihrer vorhaben sagen
sie haben heute einen eid geleistet wenn
sie diesen erfüllen wollen dann können
sie eine derartige zusage nicht
leistungen vor allen dingen wird das
dann immer begründet mit russland habe
ich will darauf hinweisen dass die nato
mitgliedsstaaten über einen etat von
1000 milliarden über ein militärbudget
von 1000 milliarden verfügen
russland dagegen nur von 63 milliarden
und wenn sie zwei prozent erreichen
würden würde sogar deutschland allein
darüber liegen meine damen und herren
lassen sie mich noch mal sehr
grundsätzlich sagen der titel der
regierungserklärung macht deutlich sie
definieren verantwortungsübernahme vor
allen dingen militärisch sie haben von
stärke gesprochen von abschreckung
gesprochen
aber meine damen und herren es gab mal
zeiten wo in deutschland mit
zurückhaltung über die rolle des
militärs bei der gestaltung deutsche
außenpolitik diskutiert wurde
die scheinen ja offensichtlich vorbei zu
sein militärische potenzial als
instrument deutscher außenpolitik haben
sie offen artikuliert programm
karrenbauer das wird die linke nicht
akzeptieren
sie reden hier im übrigen über
gelöbnisse aber sagen kein wort zum
konflikt an der straße von hormus und
sie haben auch kein wort zu syrien
gesagt
vk
hören sie auf hören sie auf aussagen zu
treffen die halbwertzeiten von nur
wenigen tagen haben und die völlig
unglaubwürdig sind die wähler die
soldaten und das parlament haben
glaubwürdigkeit verdient und keine
selbstprofilierung mit blick auf die
kanzlerschaft herzlichen dank dietmar
bartsch der fraktionschef der linken
liegt hier den finger in die wunde von
engelrod kramp karrenbauer nämlich die
frage der glaubwürdigkeit die linken
übrigens haben auch ein
entschließungsantrag tieren sie hier
gleich einbringen werden und wenden sich
gegen das zwei prozent ziel